欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
虽然这个礼拜即将迎来了中秋廉价
但是台股不想放假
今天其实涨到只差不到500点
就要创历史新高了
甚至如果还原7月8月的全息进来的话
等同于已经创下历史新高
不过今天可以看到盘面上好像是两样勤
有一些是低价股不到100块的
纷纷冲涨停板
还有一些大牛股之前不太动的
像台达电台积电今天也都转强表态
到底该怎么样来选择
像探针卡系列今天是有人跌停的
所以同一个族群里面似乎是有两极化的状况
这礼拜事情超级多
川习会要展开了这是十几年来首度
由习近平飞到美国去见川普
而川普也讲了他已经打造了一支AI的部队
还要任命所谓的AI沙皇
还有这礼拜有台积电的OIP论坛
这些都对台湾的AI股科技股到底有哪些正向影响呢
要来好好聊聊我们到底要不要报股过中秋呢
好来欢迎今天三位来宾第一位是股市师公有年老师
好师公当然要他以52年的经验告诉大家
中秋节后其实涨面蛮大的哦
大家真的能放心报股过中秋吗
今天施工很猛哦
等会告诉你
明天台股就会非常接近历史新高
但是我们选股要有逻辑
刚刚讲到川习惠
现在讲说会前会谈得非常好
到底谈了哪些事情
所谓的AI部队
AI沙皇
到底受惠台湾的厂商有哪一些
节前想要比较避险的
或是想要报股过节的
其实设备股可能会是一个很棒的选择
等一下来告诉您啰
好第二位是我们的题材猎人汉伟哥
好汉伟哥来也要讲
现在盘面上双连
很厉害
不是捷运站的双连
是连发科跟连电
带动所谓的连家军
等一下来教您了
里面还有很多地位阶的中小型股
一旦补涨
锐不可挡
那再来
如果您觉得从1700-1800档里面
选股很痛苦
其实证交所有一个指数叫普玉指数
裡面邦寧篩出了300多檔有傳產有電子叫蒲玉就是還沒有完全發光等一下浩宜哥幫您挑裡面有即將成為一塊非常厲害淬欲的好股票是什麼
好第三位呢
是我們理財達人秀
首代IP製作人
也是朴惠投顧的分析師
于晨
好于晨又來啦
那于晨今天來要聊什麼呢
他也是看聯發科
充所謂的5000塊錢
將會帶動台股
ESIC的大行情
ESIC有人創高
例如联发跟跟创意
有人第一位接
再来第二个受惠的就是封测股
但封测股今天两样勤啊
100块以下的涨停板
但是数千元的像尹危跌停板
高跟低怎么选
等一下余晨有一套很棒的法则
要来教给大家
好首先有请尤年老师
好这个这礼拜四天
每天都有忙的事情
对对对
穿习会啦对
然后还有OIP论坛啦
META也有开发者大会啊
大家只想問一件事
今天還原全息
幾乎是創歷史新高的
我們能不能報股
過到廉價後要選誰
我們先能把這三天過好嗎
這麼說
說得對
這三天我們要做什麼
OK
其實我這樣子講
從我上個禮拜
我就認為說
這個磐士應該有機會往上走
是
OK 好
那麼只是說
它會走到什麼時候
那走到什麼時候
其實還要看未來的局勢的變化
政治局勢的變化
那個是比較重要的
那我們先看看這禮拜
這個禮拜我是覺得週限收紅
大概不會有太大的問題
唯一的問題是
能不能夠在這個禮拜
創歷史新高
這個是我認為唯一的問題
好 因為它這樣磨來磨去
我剛剛只好使出還原全息
已經創高
是 對 沒錯
那我們真正要創高的是
我們不要還原全息
我們不要讓它讓我們一步
我們要貨真價實的創業性高
其實也沒有什麼困難度
你看看48218
現在已經47718了對不對
所以只差剛好500點而已
就差500點
500點你看今天我們漲多少點
538點對不對
所以施工你只要
對不對 正幣一揮
是
明天就500點了
對 好 OK 好
沒有啦 我是我們先預告一下
我認為明天最高點應該是48 209
等一下 差
48 209 你講那麼清楚就差一點點嗎 意思一下OK 好那麼我們先看一下我為什麼說認為說這個禮拜周縣收紅的機會很大
第一個就是川席會
川席會它是怎麼一回事
其實大家去注意看
每一次在川席會之前
這個美國股市都會漲
因為他都把它當成利多
因為不可能更壞了
好 不可能更壞
所以那利多
好 現在會前會
雙方都表示談得很好
談得非常好
正式的會議是9月24號
9月23號習近平就到了美國了
然後他們會先會談一下
會前會先談一下
然後9月24號是正式談
其實這一次的重點
大家都會把它擺在
就要AI還有關稅戰
還有稀土供應這些經貿領域
可是我覺得這一次習近平
他身負一個非常重要的重任
就是可能他會試圖調停
美伊之間的矛盾
所以剛才趙豪有問到我就是說
中秋節過後還有沒有行情
那我們就看他們會談的結果怎麼樣
因為今天川普還在對伊朗放話
那整個歐洲其實現在也很亂
因為說俄羅斯在對他們
做一些混合式攻擊
所以感覺上戰士很亂
但似乎沒有反應到今天
台股的盤面
是 对
其实不只是台股
其实你去看韩国股
今天表现也还不错
对 就雅股没在理
对 那美国的
美股的电子盘
今天也很强
美股也没在理
对 有些没有人在理他们
所以打仗的事情
大家都不理了
那我们现在就要看
我是觉得这一次
真正重要的任务就是说
看能不能够调停
美伊之间的事情
那我当然我是认为说
伊朗它不太可能在
美国其中大选之前会放软
可是我觉得应该会有某些的承诺
好 然后我们再来看
过去10年中秋节后
平均台股的表现
你看过后5日上涨的几率80%
后20日60%
三个月更了不起90%
也就是因为进入第四季
看来涨率就是非常高
是 对 没有错
当然最惨的意思就是
民国77年的时候
中秋节过后连续崩盘19天
那是在中秋節過後
中秋節過後
過後就開始了
連續這個19天的跌停板不過那個時候那個當然是有特殊因素所以這一次除非有特殊因素不然的話中午節過後應該可能會技術性的回檔
可是我覺得應該再差
也差不到哪裡去了
好 所以這個禮拜
連三個禮拜就四個交易而已
多空的公式會比較不連貫
這個是比較麻煩的地方
我認為它是應該會處於
區間震盪的走勢了
這個禮拜收紅沒有問題
然後接下來的三個禮拜
兩個禮拜
可能會呈現區間震盪的走勢
高點我們暫時看49500
不要看5萬這樣子就太明顯了
OK 49500
那也4999嘛
對
低檔大概最多就是46400這邊
應該會有支撐
這個華爾街大部分都用利多
來解讀川崎會
所以全職股相對會比較強勢
所以這個禮拜上半週
就禮拜一禮拜二看全值股
那禮拜三禮拜四呢
就看中小型的股票
為什麼呢
因為品種結算賣壓浮現
禮拜一禮拜二
賣壓是最重的時候
禮拜三禮拜四賣壓解除了
為什麼賣壓解除呢
因為禮拜三買股票的話
你下禮拜二再付錢就好了
所以禮拜三禮拜四
買盤會進來或會進場
所以節錢
我覺得可以做低進高出
少量短線的操作
那結後事情況
加碼或減碼
至於說低價股
我覺得低價電子股
可以暫時避避風頭
是 今天很強
對 宏基 群創 健翰
這種已經有
它有實質的基本面的股票
可以注意一下
今天當然
今天大家去看那個
漲停板的一字排下來
全部都是150塊以上的股票
低價網通 太陽能
對 流逸低
對 你只要是兩位數的股價
就有機會漲停
OK 好
然後我們就過來看
還是看台積電
台積電當初我們是用這個周線來看
我們就說它已經盤到一個尖端了
它就要表態了 對不對
這一次漲了三天
看起來是已經有一點表態
現在唯一的就是說
你還能不能夠再繼續出量
再突破2500塊來挑戰2535
其實我是覺得有機會
為什麼
因為大家看外資預估
它2027年的EPS 143塊
所以現在預估本益比才17倍
我經常在講
我以前就經常在講說
外資給予台積電的買點
是20倍的本益比
那現在呢
已經跌破買點這個三倍了
我覺得應該安全
至少安全
而且短期移動均線
馬上就要形成多頭排列
你看全部都密集在一起
包括季線都密集
都糾結在一起 對
所以現在唯一欠缺的就是
一根長紅或兩三根的長紅
它就可以把這些所有的均線
全部一起往上拉
那這樣子上去的話
那就不得了
OK 好
然後我們看一下
發獎狀
9月2號的時候有講到發哥
這個其實你一直告訴我們
你非常看好發哥
對 沒有錯
我負你的期待
今天已經突破5000元大關了
另外我們也常常在救台達電
對
算是今天它有轉牆的訊號了嗎
沒有錯 好
我們先看這個聯發科
聯發科今天是拿日線圖出來看
我們前兩次來是拿月線圖
而且是畫了那個波浪理論
對 所以我們當時講說
在這邊是第四波的盤整波
對不對
現在其實已經正式的進入第五波了
所以大家還是可以值得觀察一下
繼續觀察下去
另外台達電
台達電之前大家都對它
灰心得不得了對不對
好不好 好
可是股價上不上去
不上去
雜音比較多一些
對 就雜音比較多
其實真正的雜音
為什麼會有雜音呢
因為第二季 第三季
它其實它的毛利率都有下降
然後出貨不順
然後因為這個原料又漲價了
對它來講的話
都有造成一些殺傷力
可是現在的情況是
第四季它可能要漲價了
是
漲價了
所以它的毛利率就可以拉上來了
再從技術面來看的話
你會發現在這邊
你如果用周線看的話會更清楚
這裡已經做了兩隻腳出來
只要它能夠佔上2000塊的話
它就這邊就形成一個WD
是
這個WD要挑戰當時的這個高點
不會有太大的困難 為什麼呢
因為這裡沒有什麼套勞量
所以大家可以注意這檔股票
未來的表現
好 兩檔其實大家可以回去看
一檔施公說邪惡第五波展開了
台大電說打好第二隻腳隨機反彈
現在都驗證
對 OK 好
然後我們再來看
就是因為川普要組織AI部隊了
那麼川普還
我們任命一個新顧AI沙皇是喔是不得了哇 對時工去應徵一下我們不用啦隨便去當個跟班就去不完
OK 好
川普在喊說
AI堪比工業革命確實沒有錯
他真的堪比工業革命的
當然之前有人說
有些放話就是說
我們要減緩
請問一下誰
這個時候誰能減緩
對不對
其實川普也在講這件事
就是他要加快 他沒有要減換
對 因為現在大家都已經上車了
然後特快車在跑了
你都踩緊急上車會翻車 對不對
OK 好
那麼當然這一部分是屬於台積電的
台積電的工程概念股
然後這一點以下
它是屬於這個PCB的設備的概念股
當然你可以看
今天PCB的概念股表現是比較強的
台積電的概念股表現比較弱
可是表現比較弱就是不好嗎
其實不見得
我們來看一下陽機工程
這一檔在年線的附近
混了一段時間
對 它是除全息之後
因為它這次除全息
全息值很大
所以它直接跳空下來
看起來很弱的樣子
可是它在這裡
已經做出了一個三尊底了
已經做了三尊底
而且守住這個年線
而且它短期的移動均線
也開始糾結在一起了
五日線 十日線跟月線糾結在一起
大家注意看一下
它今天開平走低
看起來很弱 對不對
可是你去看量價的關係
它今天量
它在上禮拜五的量是很大
一個大量出來
然後拉出一個長紅
今天跌下來立刻量縮
所以量價配合度是沒有問題的
技術面來講的話
它現在的本益比
預估的本益比大概才17倍
如果它來填息的話
它除息前的那一天的收盤價是706塊
它如果來到706塊的話
它的這個本益比
也只不過19倍而已
所以我覺得它的本益比
非常低的情況之下
應該是有機會來挑戰的
當然在這邊
還有這個半年線跟季線的壓力
這個季數性的壓力
它突破
只要出量 突破問題不大
它現在的問題就是說
能不能夠完全填習
現在目標也在這裡
我覺得它是有機會的因為它今年的技術面基本面來講當然沒有問題它第二季EPS也創了歷史新高累積在手訂單要超過500億元
所以能見度一直到明年年底了
所以這支股票我覺得
現在看起來很溫吞
可是我覺得它在過去這一個多月
比較像在裝飾
好 你看到台股都只差500點
就要創新高
還有貼在年限附近的
是啊 而且還是設備股
對啊 還是接單滿手的
對 而且還中那麼多錢的股票
OK 再過來又是8021的堅點
好 也在混
對 堅點它跟剛才這個陽機不太一樣
陽機在底部混
那它這一支股票其實你可以看
它是在這個半年線 季線
所有的短期的移動均線
短中期的移動均線
全部通通線糾結在一起了
那它已經站上去三天了
好 我們就要接下來
我們現在要觀察的重點就是說
它會展開一個噴出的行情
然後把所有的軍線都往上帶
還是來一個跳空下跌
把所有的軍線往下帶
是 我們等一下也問一下陳俞辰好了
對…
因為他馬上就要決定了 OK
可是我們按照基本面來看的話
8月營收年增97.7%
再創歷史新高
累計的也是一樣
他累計的營收
上半年的累計營收
已經超越去年全年了
OK 好
那麼所以他
而且它這個探針的價格
應該會一直漲
漲到2027年
所以我覺得說
在這支股票基本面沒有問題
現在技術面看起來
也沒有什麼很大的問題
現在唯一欠缺的成交量
成交量出來的話
這支股票應該有表現的空間
好 已經站上所有的均線糾結區了
對啊
這照理來說應該要
往比較好的方向表態
是嘛 不然這費勁的心力
把這些所有的移動均線
通通纠结在那么狭小的方向
它这个区间的范围只有10块钱
是
10块钱而已
这个所有的金钱都在这边
所以应该是喷出才对吧
好 这边非常谢谢施工有内老师
谢谢
施工是比较乐观看待
中秋节后的行情
而且包括这几天
他也觉得我们不要看淡
而是来区分一下
礼拜一礼拜二
可能中小行股的卖要大一点点
礼拜三礼拜四
大家就会归对来好好布局了
尤其是这次的川席会
其實美股已經表態是往正面做表裂
如果能夠談到讓美伊之戰
稍微有一些些和緩的空間對市場也是利多而市場現在看起來喜歡的就是AI部隊這件事情台積電的供應鏈設備股還沒有動
反而是給大家上車的機會喔
好廣告回來
漢偉哥要上場啦
那漢偉哥要跟我們聊喔
現在雙聯好厲害啊
到底在這兩個聯裡面
有哪一些的子弟兵
未接低又是中小型股
會非常活潑呢
如果不會選股
從圖域指數裡面來幫您挑喔
好 虽然我们即将迎来
连续性的都是四个交易日
四个交易日放假固然开心
但是科技的脚步没有停下来
这礼拜就有台积电的OIP论坛
还有Meta也会有它的开发者大会
有很多的新产品新科技
陆陆续续都要把它拿出来讲了
所以我们看到今天盘面上
AI股科技股是相对强势的
那你会觉得联电
这个其实非常多散户的希望
慢慢的回到比較強勢的位階了
將會帶動連家軍做一番的補漲
再來的話很多人對選股覺得很難
但是證交所有一個普遇指數
裡面300多家
有傳產也有電子重點在
現在還很低調
未來會幫你賺錢
對 因為第三季快要寂寞
所以連電連家軍有集團做帳
那第四季我覺得大家可以去關注一下
有一些比較沒有被發現到的
在第四季資金行為回流之後
我覺得就有機會做一些發動的動作
所以首先我們來看一下
這禮拜相關的大事情
明天有全球的記憶體峰會
那大家可以關注一下
明天記憶體股票會有一些
大量的反彈
那9月23號是這個禮拜的重頭戲
台經的OIP論壇
相關的14奈米 16奈米
到先進製成的3DIC
CPU 細光子等等的
其實很多這些股票
可能今天都還沒有發動
那也許我覺得在禮拜三
禮拜四這兩天
都可以關注到這些
所謂有題材性的股票
有沒有隨著論壇的利多
這邊發動的情況
另外禮拜三的晚上有META開發的大會
我覺得這個重頭戲應該還是在AI眼鏡相關的
在禮拜天大摩又出了一個報告
他說全球AI半導體需求會快速的成長
看好了二三檔的股票
那重頭戲在什麼
他說雖然在2028年資本基數會放緩
那2026、2027年大幅度的成長
所以還是跟大家講
你要把握現在到明年上半年
我覺得對台股來講是一個非常好的利多窗口
那半導體的部分它的延續性會比較好
到2030年為止
相關的年負的成長率
還達到30個百分點
那對於台股來講
只要跟著北京
半導力有關的
我覺得都有機會在未來幾年
維持上好的成長性
好 那大家來看它今天的兩個主角
那聯發科當然對台股來講非常的重要
它是台灣第二大的全值股
那也是IC設計的精神指標
當它穿到歷史新高的時候
整個IC設計整個股性就會活潑起來了
所以今天股價來到5035的歷史新高
很可怕 我記得今年年初看它
才1000多塊
對 那有多次的利多題材
你發現聯發科很特別
它這個大牛皮的股票
都是用跳空漲停在跳的
在表態
對 所以我覺得今年聯發科
真的有一個比較不一樣的題材
那另外也可以看到聯電
聯電這個波段以來
其實這個跌
185跌到102也跌得滿深的
那最近我覺得也隨著它的業績
隨著它的一個漲價題材
產能利用率跟相關的新事業的佈局
股價現在是佔到所有的捐件之上
以這樣的形態來看的話
這個底型完成之後
我覺得是有機會挑戰
今年創下一個波段的一個高點
那如果這兩家都能夠往上創高的話
對他們集團的股票
我覺得會有正面的帶動
因為怎麼這樣講
就是說聯發科
它所代表的是台灣的IC設計
西式財
那當它拉到一個波段新高之後
大家第一個想到
整個西式財
IC設計會有一個比價效應
本益比拉高的空間
第二個就是
它旗下的一些小經濟們
今年其實都很悶
你看
亞信 達發 九陽 金星科
唯一比較活潑算是九陽
對 但其他都很悶
就是以前過往
如果你把今年排除的話
過往三年到五年之內
大家都看它下面的小星期
沒有來看聯發科
因為聯發科大部分時間
就是一個橫降盤整
那今年不一樣
母公司這個發光發熱
但子公司相關的小星期們
反而比較暗淡無光
但我覺得來到第四季的話
如果聯發科居為是這麼強勢的話
旗下的一些水相關的
比較小型的股票
也可以特別來看待
那聯電集團
當然每一次到了這個第四季
往往有大家期待的作戰行情
由於他的一個旗下的一些小公司們
都比較活潑一點
所以我覺得目前來看
都可以把這些所謂的
兩家聯發科跟聯電
他相關的集團股
在接下來的行情當中
列為你可以特別參考的股票
那我們來跟大家講
有哪一些可以特別關注的
好 今天漲平板的系統
對 那系統大家應該還要記得
疫情的時候他變成聯電的這個新歡
也就是說這個集團的董事長
跳下來當他的董事長所以那時候有非常多的資源藝術在系統的身上那經過這幾年的一個整理大家還是可以發現然後他事業體慢慢再改善了今天好不容易出了一個稍微帶量的攻擊
站到季線之上
那我們會講說
這樣的股票
既然已經完成了底型突破之後
大家就可以抓這個季線的關卡
如果有拉回到季線附近
我就是可以做一個縫低承接的
一般來講
第四季對艾希萊燃來講
就會比較活潑一些
那另外可以看到這個是
應該也算是聯發科比較輕的兒子叫達發
當年他掛牌之後股價一度破發
聯發科還挹注資金
去職業實施庫長股把股價拉升上來
達發在聯發科企劃裡面
負責的是所謂相關的無線網路通訊
所以我覺得對於接下來
在所謂的相關手機市場
或未來的邊緣運算AI當中
他應該都有一席之地
所以目前股價現行
他剛好佔到所有軍人之上
才是多方的一個排列
連續兩天大量外資戰案買發
那營收表現也維持一個比較量元的成長
上半年大概賺10塊錢
所以目前的本益比我覺得算是合理
所以我覺得這兩黨公司就變成說
如果大家覺得第一次季有集團作詐
有IC社會題材的話
都可以特別的留意
那當然大家會覺得說
IC社會股票可能活潑性太高了
如果我們要找一些比較安穩的標的的話
有沒有一些相關可以參考的一個東西
那剛好證交所在這幾年
發了一個普遇指數
那簡單幫大家介紹一下
什麼叫溥義指數
它選股我覺得蠻特別的
第一個它重視什麼
殖利率在台股排行前50%
第二個它重視是公司的治理
帶有59%的成分股
是公司治理評鑑前50%
另外也注意到台灣的永續評鑑
在A級上
國外的不管是所謂主權基金
或說一些比較大型的ETF
很重視這兩個評鑑
當它評鑑在高的時候
才可以納入它相關的成分股
因為全球很重視ESG的一個
永續經營
所以我覺得對於投資朋友來講的話
你選這樣的股票
第一個就是
它相對的財務數字很好
也能夠成為可能部分
國外外資能夠首選的標的
所以以這樣的情況
我們跟大家簡單去做個總結
你選普遺指數
它相對是能夠獲利
但比較不會炒作的公司
那也能夠耐震抗跌
而且它對一個產業的部分
分散度是比較好的
而且它會把一些像什麼
自由流通周轉率
成交股數等等的
前10%的公司先把它排除掉
因為他不希望說
我的指數當中有一些股票是超長超跌
對一些長期投資人來講會造成一定的困擾以他這個發行以來他的一個相關的追蹤指數的表現大概從2007年到今年的上半年為止
累積報酬率是609.95%
算是不錯的
那重點在於說
當遇到行情波動大的時候
他相對都比較能夠抵禦波動
因為剛剛看到嘛
他選擇有的是殖利率好的
而且要永續經營的
也等於說
在大盤遇到一些重挫
或是波動的時候
他應該要抗震
對 除了剛剛講的
全股特性以外
你可以發現它分散度也很好
你看它在這個新出來的一個成分股當中
電子產業佔比大概是51.36
其它傳染人家金融大概是一半
所以基本上電子金融各半
也代表說
當你看到9月份台股
金融指數一直衝高的時候
它的表現就特別的好
那另外在大中小的一個分散
跟全中的分散
我覺得在相關指數當中
算是做得比較好的一個重點的指數
那我們再來看一下
它的一個成分股
大家會覺得說
那這指數會不會就是有一點點
大家可能關注度沒那麼高
但我們講說以它的選股邏輯來看的話
當有一些優質的股票
也會成為其他ETF鎖定的標的
我們來看一下
普利指數的成分股
目前有主被動ETF鎖定的
像當中一檔到五檔
有123檔都持有它
然後有20檔ETF
同時鎖定11檔的股票
所以代表它不是完全
就是好像大家覺得
可能是這種被隱藏的珍珠
沒有低調那麼離譜啦
對 其實蠻多已經被大家發現到了
所以我覺得這個情況裡面也代表說
你可以透過它的成分股當中
去挑到好的股票
那我們大家整理出來就是說
剛剛提到了
在331檔當中有195檔
是位於公司自己的前50%
那21檔是位於前5%
所以剛剛提到了嘛
就是說你投資除了重視績效以外
我覺得大家對於公司自己的肯定
也是大家投資上面可以考慮的
因為一般來講公司自己的好公司
代表他們公司經營的狀況
也會比較良好
所以以這樣的情況來選股的話
也代表說
你選這個指數投資的成分股
可以兼顧到
對於永續投資
大家付出一點的心力
好 那來看一下
他的前十大成分股當中
第一大家是統一
你可以看到
他有這些股票
當然大家都耳熟能詳
那這樣的情況大家會覺得說
那這個指數會不會相對來看
就比較穩健一些比較溫
對 看起來是比較
抗跌保守的組合
會不會有這個問題
對 那我們來看一下
其實這當中有蠻多股票
是最近非常強勢的
來看一下
它的成分股當中你看台灣大創立子新高台灣大創立子新高是不是它跟金城的換股讓金城也創下新高對 我們講說其實對電信三雄來講
但一直是穩健的標的
大阪國大創立子新高
我覺得他們創高也是合理的
另外一檔大概非常熱門
是中砂
也跟禮拜三的台線論壇有關
股價現在已經來到916塊了
可能是新的千元股的一個
候選人了
對 它的晚漢轉強的話
我覺得對相關的半導體材料來講
我覺得都會有一些比較大的想像空間
那接下來另外一檔快要創高的是技嘉
技嘉也是大家覺得悶很久的股票
但不知不覺的
隨著最近整個AI股的一個重新轉強
它股價也快要挑戰今年以來的一個新高
所以我覺得在這樣的情況當中
就可以發現到
雖然樸語指數大家覺得好像有聽過
但是我覺得當中選了很多股票
是具備代表性的
所以我覺得現行或說
整個所謂的架構上面
有越走越強的一個跡象
那再跟大家講就是說
在這樣的情況裡面
有沒有一些可能是大家
可以特別在關注的一些相關個股
同樣是普月指數當中的
一個重要成分股
那首先我們還看到
這個工業電腦的這個股王
炎華
那炎華股價
前波穿上率子新高之後
那我覺得這個時間點
大家可以發現到
量人都還沒有出來
所以代表我覺得
這家公司跟普月指數的
一個特性一樣非常穩健
那我覺得股價的部分
只要它這個月線的關卡
能夠守穩的話
那隨著第四季的行情
我覺得是有創高的空間
因為我們可以看到
它有33檔的主被動ETF
都持有它
然後今年它的配息
去年配的分數是11.2
然後永續跟自己分數
拿到三個A的等級
在公司自己平線是前五個百分點
所以它一直以來是台灣
我覺得是非常典範的一家公司
那你可以看到今年的
這個EPS上半年就已經賺了9.05元
跟去年比較起來
今年創新高應該是沒有任何的問題
大家可能都會說
它是好公司
其實好公司是可以量化的
對不對
永續與治理拿到三個A
治理憑藉是全台股的前5%
好公司就這樣定義了嗎
對 同樣是普玉指數的成分股
玉金光啊
還蠻讓人意外的
玉金光
但它的獲利跟本益比之前還蠻合理的
對 因為之前在沒有這一段以前
它大概就是400塊到600塊
對
所以有非常多的主被動ETF持有它
而且很多高股息都有它
是
那當然如果有它
你可能要小心一下
11月份很多可能會被踢除
所以對於主要
對籌碼來講會有一定的影響的情況
但是因為現在還在9月份
所以可能大家短量不用擔心這個問題
但最少以這個情況來看
它這個波段漲勢漲得非常兇
那這個波段修正下來之後
大概在月線附近呈現一個低檔的支撐
那我們會跟大家講玉晶光
但第一件事情它本身是蘋果的題材
所以我們大致上可以看到
過去這幾年的EPS
上半年都是賺很少
對 但第三季第四季它的業績爆發期
所以今年的上半已經賺了13.99
我覺得下半年來看
如果維持去年的水準
它今年的獲利會超越去年
所以有機會去挑戰可能2024年相對的歷史新高
如果股價歷史新高搭配業績歷史新高的話
我覺得它的股價的一個穩定度會變得更高
如果普遇指數都能夠選出這樣的股票的話
我覺得在這種相對低檔比較乏人問津的時候
反正你可以特別關注到指數成分股當中
有沒有一些最近業績上來了
股價現行變好
甚至有ETF開始鎖定的標的
那看到另外一檔股票
跟航運有關
航運啊
好 育民這個
所謂的散裝航運
對 那散裝航運
當然大家可以關注到
最近的所謂運價指數也慢慢上來
那中東的局勢還是相當的緊張
那育民同樣也是
高股 ETF喜歡的一個標的
那我覺得以今年的獲利其實非常好
你可以看到
它的不管是在配息的成績
等等的一個質疑
我覺得都維持在台股的
相對好的公司當中
那今年上半已經賺了3.5億元了
跟過去這幾年相比
其實今年我覺得輕輕鬆
有機會創造率是新高
所以今年創高代表明年
也會維持一個高配息
那以目前的運價指數來看
我覺得都可以特別的留意
那像這種股票
你可以看到它整理上
它一些基本面
都是可以透過普遇指數的
這樣選股方式
提前幫你張羅選到當中
我覺得可能在低位間
你沒有注意到的時候
我覺得可以透過它的成分股
去選到好的標的
好 因為可能大家會覺得
大AI時代
講來講去都是AI股
可是普玉指數它竟然是未來有機會發酵
或是長期公司治理非常厲害的公司
它的傳產比例也不低
所以大家如果想要做好的資產配置
應該去裡面挖寶
對啊
好這邊非常謝謝漢偉哥
好漢偉哥說
當這個帶頭大哥開始衝聯電聯發科
他們旗下有很多的子弟兵
剛剛有各自選出來一些代表
他們目前位階還是比較偏低的
而且呢
過去他們有很活潑的歷史現在有沒有機會跟著大哥衝一波呢那當然如果您覺得AI股哇这个波动大那普遇指数就很有用了因为里面的话它抗震有价值公司治理好的公司
通通帮你列出来了
所以从里面挑有科技股
有低调冷门的珍珠
也有所谓的传产股
但他们都是长期经营下来
绝对不会出问题的好公司
给您做选股的搭配
当然赵海是要提醒
不管投资基金
投资ETF投资个股
投资个股
都是有赚有赔有风险的
申购钱要相悦公开说明书
好广告回来的话
余晨要上场啦
刚刚讲到联发客
我们再延伸一下吧
整个ASIC自研晶片
肯定是第四一到明年的大戏
有高有低怎么选
还有风测股动咯
但是是低价风测动
高价风测有点压力
搞不好是高价的比较好吗
好我们上个礼拜说
好像每一天都有点鬼故事
今天虽然盘面上看起来是不错的
没有受到廉价或战争的影响
可是探针系列
尹未却杀了一个跌停板
到底发生什么事情呢
这边来请教余晨了
刚刚提到
三个来宾都提到
发哥破5000
所以看来是盘面上亮点中的亮点
但你要帮我们延伸了
因为它代表的就是
自研晶片ethic
绝对是第四季到明年的大戏
再来今天的风测股表现很奇妙
百元以下很多賞聽
但是探偵系列卻是一個重錯
你會選誰 多吉
我會選靠近聯發科的
靠近聯發科的
跟聯發科越有關係越好
那不就雍智嗎
是可以考慮
那我們要討論這件事情之前
我們要注意到一個新聞
因為去年的這個時候
去年這個時候
GIMAN-9-3 橫空出世
展現了很好的簡報的邏輯能力
簡報 匯圖都比過去強很多
然後文字的辨識也變得非常強
大家記得嗎
就一開始當要用AI用GPT的時候
文字的辨識會有一些很奇怪的文字有沒有
對
可是到GIMANI 3的時候
這個能力大幅度進化
好用很多
對
那最近這一整年
坦白講GIMANI的這個進化
是
不如預期
那我們看到像GPT
前一陣子剛推出的這個GPT 6 Extra
是
然後這個Fable 5.1
這個是那個Azorpic推出的
這兩個性能都非常強
在這一年當中
都超車了GEMANI 3的這個鋒芒
可是GEMANI 4
慢慢的有一點悄悄的衝出江湖好 所以今年的話我們準備迎接GEMANI 4 Pro對 這個GEMANY 4它現在還沒有開始正式發表可是在論壇上面
已經可以看到它一些跑分的成績
它跑分成績
可是它對手跟這個GPT-6
跟這個Cloud Fable 5.1來比的話
至少都不相上下
那你可以看一下
比如說像它的成本
成本的部分
GEMANY 4低很多
這很重要
對 那再來就是說
比如說像這個編寫程式的能力
或者是說像金融分析
法律任務等等
這個都比Google
都比GPT6
然後還要比Fable 5.1
都還要表現來得強硬
所以GIMNI
它到底好不好用
它其實表現真的不錯
重點是它背後的工程是誰
背後的工程就是這個
這是它自己的晶片
TPU Google自研晶片
這個TPU帶來怎麼樣的經濟效益
Google Cloud就說
這裡面圖上面有兩條線
一條是實線 一條是虛線
那這個實線代表說
如果是Google Cloud
他用GPU的方法來去做運算的話
他成本大概要兩年才會回本
大概要兩年多
兩年多會回本
好 GPU太貴了
GPU對 GPU稍微比較貴一些
可是他自己用他自己的TPU
他回本時間很神奇
變成一年多
那Google告訴我們說
他的客戶跟他簽的合約
大概都是五年以上
所以你想想看
原本兩年回本的合約
它現在一年就回本了
那表示說這個TPU的算力表現
可以幫它帶來更大的經濟價值
就是回應到趙華最前面講的
Asi的大時代
其實你可以看這個Google TPU
它的這個每個世代在推出
誰最受惠
你這太難了吧
對你是來回禮台達恩秀出考題的嗎
那這張表上秘密麻麻好多
秘密麻麻看起來有點複雜
其實重點只有兩個
重點只有兩個
第一個重點呢
當然是我們發哥佔據很多嘛
佔據很多塊嘛
先問MTK這三個字
MTK就是我們聯發哥
那上面橫軸這個是代表每個晶片世代
TPU的晶片世代在推進
那當然是MTK越多
表示他拿下晶片越多嘛
這是其中一
可是這個還不是最大的重點
不然呢
重點是這一欄
這一欄全部都被槓掉了
那這一欄
表示什麼意思
它是說TPU在第九代的時候
它原本有一顆兩顆三顆的晶片可是這一顆晶片通通都取消了為什麼可能考量成本 考量性能等等的一些想法
那誰被取消了
Broadcom
博通的 博通晶片被取消了
所以原本從TPU的V9
可能就是博通有好幾顆
然後聯發科也有好幾顆
可是現在博通被取消一顆
對於聯發科來說
它是什麼意思
它是Share again
他就市占率就變大
本來1 2 3 4 對不對
然後發哥1 2 3 4
但是現在發哥還是4
博通變成3了
所以對於這個
TPU的市占率來說
聯發科就是最大的贏價
那接下來重點就是說
既然聯發科來了
聯發科會隨著這個 TPU的貢獻
未來也會越來越棒
那重點是
那接下來我們投資的方向
當然就是要去朝著聯發科
來去做貼近
對啊 就除了他
我們還是希望知道有沒有別人
例如說最近創意也很厲害
可是世新KY就有點躺在地上
我們當然希望能夠找到
可以補漲或是還有潛力的
是那我們講到說
這個整個A10的概念果
你看這上面的這個表現
今天表現都大概大部分都還不錯
不過世新KY也因為有說
有幫人家投片的關係
所以毛利率會受到一點影響
怎麼看這個事情
沒有錯
可是它的營收會變得非常
營收會變大
營收會變超級超級的大
對 那那個
毛利率的部分
因為你做Tenkey
毛利率多多少少會下降
其實聯發科的毛利率
它也會慢慢下降
可是它有一個好處
就是說它的費用率
它延發費用也會慢慢降下來
所以它整體來講
以這些IP廠來看的話
它的獲利還是會往上來去做推升
所以你看跟聯發科廠商
跟聯發科關係特別好的
比如說像
我今天有幫大家列第三季
營收的達成率
那這營收達成率就是說
現在我們把七加八月的營收加起來
去跟法人預期比一比
達成大概多少
你可以發現跟聯發科關係較好的
大概都有六成六成六以上
這表示如果說
九月份的營收
輕輕鬆鬆喇喇喇喇喇
不要月減太多
就算是小月減
他還是有機會
要讓法人要持續來去做上修
好 上修
而且可能對於明年
搞不好還有上修的機會
對 沒有錯
那我們就來看一下
這幾天公司的財務表現
因為聯發科的這個
剛剛兩位專家已經講很多
技術面了我就不講
所以你要講一些不一樣的
對 重點是在於說評價面的部分
聯發科評價面
因為聯發科畢竟已經
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕